older children all over the country are
going to summer camp right now and a
growing number of those camps have new
facial recognition technology to help
parents keep up with their kids every
day 33 states use the software from
Waldo photos that can identify kids and
cam photos Toni de copal went to one
camp that's embracing the idea in spite
of privacy concerns Tony good morning
good morning it's just about camp
drop-off time right now the camp we
visited on Long Island says about 15% of
families have enrolled in this new
facial recognition technology program
most of them seem to like the short term
convenience of it but others worried
about the implications of a technology
that can pick individual kids out of the
crowd with the rise of the internet and
more recently smartphones daily digital
updates from your children at summer
camp is the new norm at rolling river
day camp on Long Island they're using
facial recognition technology to help
keep parents connected as camp director
does any part of you think twice about
facial recognition and summer camp in
the same sentence I think that parents
are looking for convenience they're very
busy in their daily lives so if they can
have a software program that can just
send them a text alert when pictures go
up about their kid I think it just makes
it more convenient for them and it makes
the overall experience a lot better for
them the technology used at rolling
River is called Waldo photos the
software uses an algorithm and a family
provided selfie of a camper it scans
photographs taken at the camp that are
uploaded to Waldo the software then
matches those images to the selfie and
sends the camp's pictures in text
messages to parents if not for this what
would you use I would scan through
hundreds of pictures until I found him
did you have any hesitation about
participating in what is facial
recognition technology I didn't know I
know that some people have a lot of
concerns about privacy but you know I
already had given the permission to the
camp to take his picture and to put it
on Facebook and Instagram so to me it's
that many steps removed to let Waldo
have the facial recognition I think most
people's perception when they hear
facial recognition is they think oh my
gosh this company has run facial
recognition on me or one of my family
members so now they have this stored
somewhere rodney rice is founder and CEO
of Waldo photos all we collect is the
reference image to use in with the
facial recognition and your mobile
number and your name we don't collect
your addresses we don't collect your
email etc if I'm a parent at one of
these camps I'm gonna want to know how
are these photos being stored
are they encrypted wired senior writer
EC lapowski says there are still risks
long as facial recognition is still in
its development phase I think that
regulators should be there helping these
companies write the rules of the road at
least as it regards privacy now Waldo
photos is an entirely voluntary
application you need to opt in if you
want to use the service and the CEO
tells us that if you don't want to use
it just don't opt in that simple John
won't be using it yeah well I think it
would bring peace of mind I know your
parents and it adds to your family photo
album yes that's right gives you options
thank you Tony